إذاً ما هو Qiskit؟
Qiskit هو مجموعة أدوات تطوير برمجيات مفتوحة المصدر
للعمل مع أجهزة الحوسبة الكمومية
على مستوى الـ circuit
والخوارزميات ووحدات التطبيقات، وهذه المجموعة
تتيح لأي شخص برمجة أجهزة كمومية حقيقية من
لابتوبه، وبسطرين من الكود تقدر توصل
لعدة أنظمة كمومية، من الموصلية الفائقة
إلى الـ qubit المحاصر. تريد محاكاة سلوك الحاسوب الكمومي؟
غيّر سطراً واحداً فقط من الكود
وشغّل محاكاة الـ circuit الكمومي على الـ simulator
عالي الأداء خاصتنا. Qiskit هو أداة يستخدمها
عشرات الآلاف من الناس حول العالم، كلهم يحاولون
بناء المستقبل، سواء كنت باحثاً أو مطوراً
أو مجرد شخص يريد البدء
Qiskit يوفر عدداً من
الميزات اللي تناسب احتياجاتك
وتتيح لأي شخص فعل أشياء مثل
بناء أول circuit كمومي ليك
وتشغيل خوارزميات كمومية متعددة المجالات
ودراسة الظواهر الكمومية الأساسية
ربما الوقت المناسب الحين هو الوقت المثالي لتنضم بنفسك
وتلاقي كل الأدوات اللي تحتاجها
بما فيها أجهزة كمومية حقيقية
والـ SDK عبر Qiskit
ومجتمع سعيد بترحيبك
والإجابة على أي سؤال عندك في الطريق
تقدر تبدأ اليوم
على Qiskit